hey youtubers its charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 2 video actually
creatively it was a pretty good episode
and it did a good job of setting up what
the court of owls plan is forgot them
and how they're using all these criminal
characters using the maniacs have you
want to think about him it's still
really early in the season so what we're
just seeing now is Team Batman slowly
come together as team Arkham slowly
comes together that's why I'm thinking
about him we haven't really gotten to
full-blown court of owls yet they're
just kind of laying the seeds for that
so just careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
starting with top five moments number
five Theo
vs. the mayor last week Theo presided
over the transition between
commissioners they said he was there in
the mayor's absence so now we just got
the payoff where the mayor has been and
it's Richard kind back from season one
he was the guy that played the mayor at
season one who is actually a pretty
terrible person himself my guess is is
that his plan for Arkham City just
clashed with what the court of owls
planned for Arkham City is Theo explains
there's a grander plan for Gotham now
season one was all about Arkham City so
I think that this is actually a much
bigger deal Arkham City is probably big
part of it I'll be I'll be interested to
see how much they reference Arkham
specifically in terms of the big
development this Arkham Asylum and then
there's Arkham City like the larger area
that everyone was fighting over last
year they've done a really good job with
the comedy this year so far like I mean
I mean Gotham is meant to be a little
bit of a darker show it's Batman Batman
is a dark character so naturally when
they're at the newspaper with the follow
up like where's the mayor WTF did he go
you just see people casually flying by
in the window yes the message with the
bodies was a little over the top but I
felt like it totally worked in the
context of this episode I'm totally on
board with their sense of humor just as
long as they stay consistent the tone of
the villain scenes have been a lot
better some of the villain characters
are pretty interesting so far and I'm
really digging the way they're using
cinematography in special music during
the villain scenes to just make it a
little bit trickier if you look at the
scenes that the villains have like
whenever they're chasing down the bus
later in the episode in any time it's
just them in the scene they twist the
camera they darken the light and they
give them their special villain
soundtracks like their special villain
theme music that they've given them
which is actually great I actually think
there's a good shot they could release a
soundtrack of this stuff whenever the
season's over wants number four Theo
explains the court of owls plan to the
maniacs
so here's the deal Jerome and his
friends are just gonna destroy the city
as much as
possible and then the court of owls is
going to walk in clean everything up and
be lauded as the saviors the stagecraft
was a lot of fun there been some images
and some of the trailers to of like
Jerome all done up like a ringmaster
there's a certain theatricality to all
the best Batman villains so I feel like
this is automatically totally on point
with the universe a really good counter
example of this would be to go to the
flash where everything is done in broad
daylight there aren't a whole lot of
scenes that happen at night everything
is a little bit lighter the characters
are just a little bit happier a little
bit sillier all of those comic-book
characters still very true to their
characters in the comics thematically
but it's a very different tone from
Batman comics and their characters the
funny thing is always when you see
characters from say like Batman comics
show up in other people's comics that's
where you start to get into continuity
problems which is kind of what it makes
it harder for TV shows to crossover when
they have dramatically different tones I
know a lot of people are wondering about
Gotham crossing over with all the other
shows just just to be clear
Gotham is supposed to take place in the
late 80s early 90s so this is all
happening like 20 years before what's
happening on the flash right now on to
number three Alfred smashes Bruce's
computer and he loses his [ __ ] it is
kind of fun to watch little kid actors
lose their [ __ ] I feel like he's doing a
pretty good job by the time this series
makes it to like season 4 season 5 david
Mizzou's the actor here will be a
full-blown teenager he'll actually be
old enough to play a real Batman but
typically you don't see them giving
scenes like this to actors like them
just flying off the handle just because
it ends up looking really silly so I
feel like the actor David mezuzah
actually did a pretty good job with this
because we're kind of in like a mini
version of the Batcave
I mean there's even like a penny with a
dinosaur on the desk there
I feel like this computer kinda reminds
me of the Michael Keaton bat-computer
down in the Batcave from his first 80s
Batman movie just you know very big very
tactile did anybody else buy it
when Bruce fired Alfred like did you
think that he was gonna go and have some
some separate Arkoff on the show for the
rest of the season I thought for a
minute that might happen but then they
totally took it back a little while
later in the episode I feel like they
could have waited till next week to do
that but the whole thing about this
episode was the villains coming together
in a really cohesive way in the heroes
coming together - and you can't do that
when they're all going off in different
directions so I totally get what they
did with the Alfred Bruce drama on the
number 2 enter Lucius Fox stage left
this is just fun because Morgan
Freeman's Lucius Fox character was so
integral to making Batman's new
technology originally giving him new
technology technically it's the R&D
department that developed all that stuff
in the Dark Knight trilogy been in the
context of the TV show Lucius Fox feels
very remorseful about not being able to
do anything to help Thomas Wayne just
because they've been so close for so
long he is a genius he's helping them
fix the proto back computer
so now Lucius is officially on Team
Batman which I just think is awesome so
far the actors done a pretty good job
but I feel like we're gonna need to see
some more Lucius Fox scenes to get a
sense for how the show is gonna be using
him he's supposed to be a main character
of this series so he should be in most
of the episodes I'm kind of waiting now
for Theo's character to cross over with
the Wayne board like is he gonna show up
as like this mystery new member of the
board I finally of course on my number
one WTF moment the villains attacked the
police station and kill Commissioner
Essen there's a whole lot to unpack here
like you have what's going on with nygma
and Miss Kringle off to the side you
have what's going on between Barbara and
Jim I know a lot of people are wondering
if Barbara's gonna be like the new
Harley Quinn I don't think they're ever
gonna call her Harley Quinn but yes
she's wearing red gloves she's got a
crazy laughs already which i think is I
think is pretty good I mean she's gonna
have to work on her villain laughs it's
just I don't think they would do Harley
Quinn if they weren't gonna give her
Harley Quinn's backstory regardless of
which TV show it is usually when they
bring a big comic book character on they
try to be as true as possible to their
origin story from the comics
even though Gordon had a lot of scenes I
feel like his best scenes were with
Harvey who I'm so happy to see that he
got together with that woman from the
Scarecrow episodes last season that's
where she showed up as part of that
storyline we've seen far too little
Harvey so far but it seems like he's
back on board now he's back on Team
Batman this episode was really more
about Jerome taking power in the
Maineiacs starting their mission to just
destroy Gotham as much as possible so
not super heavy on some of the hero
characters like even Leslie Thompkins
was barely in this episode and just for
reference if you guys have noticed this
they've been calling her Lee
that's just short for Leslie I heard him
saying during episode 1 but I didn't
think too much of it it's just sad a
little bit weird and after I heard him
say it again in this episode I was just
like okay I guess they're gonna call her
Lee from now on the cool thing about
Morena Baccarin real life is that
supposedly she's having a baby with Ben
McKenzie her yo her co-star Ben McKenzie
on the show fried as much Batman fanfic
as you want but there was also an
interview with her recently where she
talked about really liking having the
the weekly schedule of being on a TV
show as in she had no plans to leave
Gotham anytime soon so don't be
surprised if Leslie Thompkins continues
to be a main character into season 3
season 4 you know however many years the
show continues it's just when you're an
actor it's really hard to raise children
when you have to like fly all over the
world so when you're on a TV show it's a
much more regular schedule so that's why
you see actors who are trying to raise
families choose TV shows over doing
movies a lot of times but let me know
what's your favorite moment from the
episode
and what's your favorite thing about the
villain so far like how do you feel
about the way the show has changed the
way it portrays villains I feel like
they just have a stronger sense of their
creative style when they do when they're
dealing with these characters and it's
so far it's actually come across really
well it looks a lot better on screen
than season one did if you do have any
friends who aren't watching Gotham yet
just tell them Uncle Harvey says start
watching the show right now because this
is actually starting to get really good
and speaking more about the court of
owls the way they explain how they're
doing it on the show is that they're
gonna slowly tease it out like someone
isn't going to say court of owls for a
while but you're going to see court of
owls things happening in the background
so be sure to look for Easter eggs and
clues like as tigress is closing her
sniper rifle case you actually see what
looks kind of like an owl on the outside
of the wood that's definitely on purpose
like they wouldn't do that unless they
wanted you to see an hour there anytime
there's a multi-million dollar TV show
that is really expensive to shoot
nothing makes it on screen unless they
really want it to be there the other
really big news this week is that agents
of shield season 3 is starting tomorrow
now the big deal is that they're doing
Inhumans and supposedly like I haven't
seen it yet but the critic friends that
I know that have seen it say it's like a
whole new pilot for the show as if like
the show is completely different from
the ground up everything I've heard has
been extremely good so if you felt like
agents of shield season 1 & 2 just were
not your cup of gamma then now is the
time to start watching that too I always
get really excited when TV shows just
you know don't seem like they're as good
as they can be and then they come back
roaring with like each successive season
so like season 4 probably gonna be way
better than season 3 and over in the DC
Universe the same goes for flash and
arrow which are coming back next week so
like a whole bunch of comic book TV
coming back this
week in next week make your bodies ready
and be sure to subscribe to get
everything so while you guys wait for
everything to post you can click here
for all my Gotham Batman videos I did a
video kind of explaining what's going on
with court of owls and you can click
here for the latest trailer from agents
of shield season 3 thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow